half new york times columnist david
brooks looks at the growth of suburbs in
america in discussing his new book on
paradise drive
first what's the matter with kansas
thomas frank on how republicans have
gained the support of blue-collar and
rural americans
well good news good evening everybody
we'd like to thank you all a lot for
braving the brutal northeastern kansas
heat and humidity i know it's not august
but
for coming down to let tom know that
maybe not everyone in his home state has
reacted negatively or completely so
anyway to his controversial new book
we'd also like to thank that venerable
institution the lawrence public library
and of course lawrence bookstore the
raven which is a very fine example of an
independent bookstore you should support
for co-sponsoring this event this
evening
tom is a native kansan and he did a year
or so here up on the hill before
completing his undergrad degree at the
university of virginia
he then went on to corral his doctorate
at the university of chicago while there
he founded the baffler a journal of
savage cultural criticism available at
your finer bookstores he's also authored
three books the conquest of cool in
which he deconstructed the culture
industry and its love affair with the
substanceless imagery of rebellion and
confrontation and one market under god
in which he exposed global consumer
capitalism's fever dream of a wondrous
new economy utopia is wearing no clothes
well before the dot-com burst that made
fools of business page editors across
america
in his new book what's the matter with
kansas he turns the same critical eye on
the manufacture of a consensus of
righteous indignation that has
transformed the american political
landscape and allowed the conservative
right to hijack the rhetoric of
rebellion and style republican
millionaire anarchists
as the creative extreme radical vanguard
in a new class war against the
entrenched elites of uptight unhip new
deal great society conformity
all tom's work focuses on this
perversion the cultural inversion that
has occurred since the 1960s which
trumpets the free market as the friend
of the weak and powerless and proclaims
the most outrageous social darwinist
fantasies to be earthy common sense
tom frank is the writer for an era in
which henry rollins from black flag that
calvinist avatar of positive mental
attitude and also corporate america's
favorite management theorist is a uso
performer bucking up the morale of our
fighting boys in iraq in the grand
tradition of that subversive performance
artist bob hope
being from extreme southwestern kansas
myself a region radically transformed
dude
by the boardroom buncombe and of
trickle-down voodoo and rock and roll
republicanism i've had plenty of
opportunity to painfully ponder the
economic and social consequences of this
inversion or perversion at work
and the question that plagues me
like so many of the rest of us is how
the hell did this happen
how does the interest of america's ceos
magically become identical with those of
the folk of the soil and salt of the
earth
tom's new book attempts to answer this
question
and may just be the holler in the
wilderness we kansas may need to rally
around in order to effectively challenge
this kafka-esque tendency in american
social and political life
so
without further ado
let's have a warm humid lawrence welcome
for thomas frank
thank you tad
and i want to start right off with
a uh the story was not much of a story
it's just a fact about this inversion in
action that really struck me when i
first found out about it and that is
that
the poorest county in america
which isn't in appalachia or the deep
south it actually happens to be on the
great plains up in nebraska
a region of struggling ranchers and
dying farm towns and in the election of
2000 this county
went for the republican candidate for
president george w bush
by a majority of greater than 80 percent
now this puzzled me when i first uh read
about it
as it puzzles many of the people that i
know for us it's always the democrats
that are the party of the workers and
the poor and the weak and the victimized
figuring this out my friends and i think
is basic
this is like part of the
part of the abcs of adulthood if you
will and when i told uh when i told a
friend of mine about that high plains
county that was so enamored of president
bush she was perplexed and she asked me
this
how can anyone who's ever worked for
someone else vote republican
how could so many people get it so wrong
i think her question is apt in fact i
think it is in some ways the preeminent
question of our times
people getting their fundamental
interests wrong
is what american political life is all
about
this species of derangement
is the bedrock of our civic order it's
the foundation on which everything else
rests
this species of derangement has put the
republicans in charge of all three
branches of government it's elected
presidents senators
governors it shifts the democrats to the
right and then impeaches bill clinton
just for fun just throws that in as a
bonus you know
if you earn over three hundred thousand
dollars a year i think you owe a great
deal
to this derangement
raise a glass sometime to those indigent
high plains republicans as you
contemplate your good fortune it's
thanks to their self-denying votes that
you
are no longer burdened by the estate tax
or by troublesome labor unions or
meddling banking regulators
thanks to the allegiance of these sons
and daughters of toil you were able to
buy two rolexes this year instead of one
and take that tour of indochina by sedan
chair
or perhaps you're one of those many many
millions of average americans who see
nothing deranged about this at all and
for you this picture of hard times
conservatism makes perfect sense and
it's the opposite phenomenon working
class people who insist on voting for
liberals that strikes you as an
indecipherable puzzlement
maybe you see it the way a bumper
sticker that i once spotted in kansas
city puts it a working person that
supports democrats is like a chicken
that supports colonel sanders
maybe you were one of those who stood up
for america way back in 1968 sick of
hearing those rich kids in beads bad
mouth the country every night on tv
maybe you knew exactly what richard
nixon meant when he talked about the
silent majority the people whose hard
work was rewarded with constant insults
from the network news and the
know-it-all college professors none of
them interested in anything you had to
say
or maybe it was the liberal judges that
got you mad as hell casually rewriting
the laws of your state according to some
idea that they had picked up at a
cocktail party
or ordering your town to shoulder some
billion dollar desegregation scheme that
they had dreamed up all on their own
are turning criminals loose to prey on
the hard-working and the industrious
maybe it was ronald reagan that pulled
you into the conservative swirl
the way that he had of uh talking about
that sunshiny glenn miller america that
you remembered back from the time before
everything went to hell
or maybe you were pushed maybe it was
bill clinton that made a republican out
of you with his patently phony
compassion and his obvious contempt for
average non-ivy league americans the
ones that he had the nerve to order into
combat even though he himself took the
coward's way out when his turn came
this great movement to the right
that we've had over the last 36 odd
years is so familiar
i think that probably everybody in this
room has a conversion story that they
can tell how their dad had been a union
steel worker say and a stalwart democrat
but how one day all their brothers and
sisters started voting republican
or how their cousin
gave up on methodism and started going
to the pentecostal church out in the
edge of town
or how they themselves just got so sick
and tired of being scolded for eating
meat or for wearing clothes emblazoned
with chief elena weck that one day fox
news started to seem fair and balanced
to them after all
now each of these uh things that i have
described are expressions of what i call
what i call in the book the great
backlash
which is a style of conservatism that
first came snarling onto the national
stage in response to the partying and
protests of the late 1960s
and while earlier forms of conservatism
had emphasized fiscal sobriety the
backlash mobilizes voters instead with
explosive social issues summoning up our
outrage over everything from busing to
blasphemous art which outrage it then
marries to pro-business economic
policies
so cultural anger
is marshaled to achieve economic ends
and it's these economic achievements
that are the movement's greatest
monuments
after all it's the backlash
that's made possible the great
international free market consensus
of recent years with all of the
privatization and deregulation and
unionization that are its components
it's the backlash that ensures that
republicans will continue to be returned
to office even when their free market
miracles fail
and their libertarian schemes don't
deliver and their new economy collapses
in pieces it's the backlash that makes
possible the policy pushers fantasies of
globalization
and a free trade empire that are foisted
upon the rest of the world with such
self-assurance
because some artist decides to shock the
hicks by dunking jesus in urine
every country on earth must remake its
economy along the lines preferred by the
republican party usa
now the great backlash has made the
laissez-faire revival possible but this
doesn't mean
that it speaks to us in the manner of
the capitalists of old you know invoking
the divine right of money
or demanding that the lowly learn their
place in the great chain of being
on the contrary the backlash tells us
that it is a foe
of the elite that it's the voice of the
unfairly persecuted that it's a
righteous protest of the people on
history's receiving end
that its champions today control all
three branches of government matters not
a wit that its greatest beneficiaries
are the wealthiest people on the planet
does not give it pause
in fact
backlash leaders systematically downplay
the politics of economics the movement's
basic premise
is that culture outweighs economics as a
matter of public concern that values
matter most as one backlash book title
put it and on these grounds it rallies
citizens who would once have been
reliable partisans of the new deal to
the standard of conservatism
now once uh conservatives are in office
of course the only old-fashioned
situation that they really care to
revive is the economic one of low wages
and lacks regulation
and over the last three decades they
have smashed the welfare state
reduced the tax burden on corporations
and the wealthy and generally returned
the country to a 19th century pattern of
wealth distribution
so thus we have the primary
contradiction of the backlash this is a
working class movement that has done
incalculable historic harm
to working-class people
now the leaders of the backlash may talk
christ but they walk corporate
values may matter most to voters but
they always take the backs back seat to
the needs of money once the elections
are won and this is a basic earmark of
the phenomenon absolutely consistent
across its decades-long history abortion
is never halted school prayer never
comes back the culture industry is never
forced to clean up its act
now all this is vexing for people like
me who want to write about the backlash
and you might expect it to vex the
movement's true believers even more
their grandstanding leaders never
deliver
their fury mounts and mounts and
nevertheless they turn out every two
years to return their right wing heroes
to office for a second a third a 20th
try
the trick never ages the illusion never
wears off you vote to stop abortion
and you receive a rollback in capital
gains taxes
you vote to make our country strong
again and you receive
de-industrialization
you vote to get those politically
correct college professors and you
receive electricity deregulation
you vote to get the government off our
backs and you receive conglomeration and
monopoly everywhere from media to
meatpacking
you vote to stand tall against
terrorists and you receive social
security privatization you vote to
strike a blow against elitism and you
receive a social order in which wealth
is more concentrated than ever before in
our lifetimes in which workers have been
stripped of power and ceos are now
rewarded in a manner that is beyond
imagining
as a formula for holding together a
dominant political coalition the
backlash sometimes seems so improbable
and so self-contradictory
that liberal observers often have
trouble believing that it's actually
going on that's actually happening that
this keeps taking place they don't get
it
and for the republican party to present
itself as the champion of working class
america strikes them as such an
egregious reversal of political
tradition
as they just dismiss the whole
phenomenon they brush it off they don't
want to think about it
and the great backlash they believe it's
just not worth taking seriously it's
nothing but crypto racism or a disease
of the elderly or the random gripings of
religious rednecks or the protests of
angry white men
feeling left behind by history
but i think
that to understand the backlash this way
is to miss its power as an idea and its
broad popular vitality i mean it keeps
coming despite everything a plague of
bitterness capable of spreading from the
old to the young
from protestant fundamentalists to
catholics and jews and from the angry
white man to every demographic shading
imaginable
and it matters not at all that the
forces that triggered the original
backlash back in the late 1960s have
long since disappeared from american
life the backlash roars on undiminished
its rage carrying easily across the
decades
the think about it the confident
liberals that led america back in those
days in the 1960s are a dying species
the new left with its gleeful
obscenities and its contempt for the
flag is pretty much extinct altogether
the whole affluent society of the
post-war era with its paternalistic
corporations and its powerful labor
unions
fades further into the ether with each
passing year
and yet the backlash continues to dream
its terrifying dreams
of national decline epic lawlessness and
betrayal at the top regardless of what's
actually going on in the world
now if you uh
if you turn on cnn
you know i i was staying in a motel this
morning i turn it on of course there it
was it's in every motel in the world and
you watch the commercials and if you
look at america from that perspective it
seems like a very reasonable place
where
everything works everything fits
everything makes sense all the big
problems have been resolved
and it even looks like an age of reason
a new economy that we are in with the
websites singing each to each
with a mall down the way that every week
that has miraculously anticipated are
subtly shifting tastes and with a global
economy whose rich rewards just keep
flowing
but on closer inspection i sometimes
think that this country we live in looks
more like a panorama of madness and
delusion worthy of hieronymus bosch of
sturdy blue-collar patriots reciting the
pledge while they strangle their own
life chances
of small farmers proudly voting
themselves off the land
of devoted family men carefully seeing
to it that their children will never be
able to afford college or even proper
health care
of working class guys in midwestern
cities cheering as they deliver up a
landslide for a candidate whose policies
will end
their way of life will transform their
entire region into a rust belt we'll
strike people like them blows from which
they will never recover
okay that's the first uh chapter of the
book or part of it anyway
but i can't just leave it at that right
i gotta keep going because you're
wondering like how the hell does this
work
how and you know how are we supposed to
square all of these circles
how is it that our conservative rebels
and you you all know who i'm talking
about
how is it that our conservative rebels
can profess to hate elites
and i was just listening to rush
limbaugh this morning i was walking
through the old thrift store and there
they had rush on the loudspeakers and he
was he was letting the liberal elites
have it how can these people profess to
hate elites but somehow excuse from
their fury the corporate world even when
it has so manifestly screwed them over
how can they find recruits
for an uprising of the common people
that only makes the upper crust even
crustier than ever
how do they decide that one man i.e john
kerry yachtsman
is a frenchified snob for being rich
but that another bit that the riches of
another guy i.e george w bush tough guy
show him to be a regular fellow how do
they do that how do they get that all
straight
now i want to suggest that at the center
of all of this is a way of thinking
about social class that both encourages
class hostility and that simultaneously
denies the economic basis of the
grievance
class the conservatives will tell us
is not really about money or birth or
even occupation it is primarily a matter
of authenticity that most valuable
cultural commodity class is about what
kind of car you drive and where you shop
and how you pray and especially what
kind of coffee you drink
you know the lattes right
and it's only secondarily only
secondarily is class about the job that
you do or the income that you make what
makes you a member of the noble
proletariat is not work per se but
unpretentiousness humility
and all the rest of the various virtues
that our pundit corps keeps spotting out
in red state america the producer class
they tell us doesn't care about
unemployment or a dead-end life or a
boss that makes 500 times as much as
they do no
out here in places like kansas both
workers and their bosses are always
supposed to be united in disgust at
those affected college boys at the next
table always prattling on about french
cheese and villas in tuscany and the big
ideas for running things that they read
about in books
so these are the real parasites right
not enron
not coke industries
not merrill lynch
college students intellectuals you guys
me
the
now the key element in this repackaging
of social class is the idea of a liberal
elite
as you all know this idea has taken many
forms over the years since it was
basically introduced by richard nixon's
vice president spiro agnew way back in
the late 60s
this idea has taken many forms but in
its basic outlines the grievance has
always remained pretty much the same our
culture and our schools and our
government backlashes insist are
controlled by an over-educated ruling
class that is contemptuous of the
beliefs and the practices of the masses
of the regular people
those who run america the theory holds
are despicable self-important show-offs
they are a feat to use one of agnew's
favorite terms
they are arrogant
they are snobs
they are liberals
now conservatism on the other hand is
supposed to be the doctrine of the
oppressed majority
unlike classical burkian conservatism
the backlash does not defend some
established order of things it accuses
it rants it points out hypocrisy and
gleefully pounces on contradictions and
while liberals are supposed to always be
using their control of the airwaves and
the newspapers and the schools to
persecute average americans the
republicans are supposed to be the party
of the disrespected the downtrodden the
forgotten and they're always the
underdog always in rebellion against a
haughty establishment always rising up
from below so and this is the important
point all claims on the right in other
words advance from victimhood this is
important to remember
and if you immerse yourself in backlash
culture which i've been doing for the
last two and a half years you will find
that backlashers constantly revel
in fantasies of their own marginality
and persecution in fact there's even a
bestseller by rush limbaugh's brother
that's just called persecution and it
was in the new york times bestseller
week list for weeks and weeks and weeks
it's if you follow their list serves
it's not uncommon to uh to see uh emails
in which conservatives will greet fellow
conservatives with uh phrases like
fellow rubes of the flyover you find the
same thing in their magazines
in particular the magazine the american
enterprise which is published by the
american enterprise institute the think
tank which gave you the war with iraq
but here's how an article in that
magazine started a few years ago i'm
stupid and if you're reading this you
probably are too right because the
liberal elite is always you know mocking
you and this sort of thing and then
there is another thing that you notice
uh in conservative movement culture is
this all too common spectacle of
conservatives boasting of their own
subversiveness which you actually see
more than you would think the phrase
politically incorrect for example is one
that they love to throw around
in fact it's the title of a book by
ralph reed
you all know who ralph reed is right
yeah in chicago they don't know who that
is
[Laughter]
john leo who is a conservative columnist
for u.s news and world report actually
wrote a book in 1994 that he called two
steps ahead of the thought police right
because the thought police are after him
the you and me were after him and in in
2001 he the book that he that he
published in 2001 he gave it the title
incorrect thoughts which ironically as
it happens was also the title of a 1981
album by the hardcore punk band the sub
humans which i listen to
which i you know there's these there's
weird overlaps here i listened to that
album a lot while i was writing this
book believe you me anyhow the object of
all of this uh
breast beating under doggery
is is that the conservatives engage in
is not to unvictimize the average
americans that they claim to speak for
and indeed that's ruled out almost from
the get-go while most of us uh think of
politics as a kind of machiavellian
exercise in which actors make alliances
and take practical steps to advance
their interests the backlash is
something very very different it's a
crusade in which your material interests
are suspended
in favor of vague cultural grievances
that are supposed to be both all
important
and yet incapable of ever being assuaged
and i'm not exaggerating this uh think
about it when the when the movements
leaders pick their cultural battles and
let me just take a step back here and
point out that the leaders of this
movement are very intelligent people
very canny people these are the people
that gave you the
florida recount
victory back in 2000 very canny
strategic minded people but when they
choose their cultural battles
they seem to always choose cultural
battles where victory is impossible
where their followers feelings of
powerlessness will simply be dramatized
and their alienation aggravated
a good example here is the backlash fury
object du jour while i was writing this
book which was the alabama ten
commandments monument you all remember
that
which was erected deliberately in order
to provoke an aclu lawsuit and which
everyone knew from the very start would
come to no other possible end than being
pried loose and carted away everybody
knew it was going to end that way or
take for example the great abortion
controversy which has put such a dent
into the politics of this state and
which mobilizes millions of people
across the country and yet which cannot
be put to rest without a supreme court
decision overturning roe v wade or a
constitutional amendment
as culture war the backlash was born to
lose
its goal is not to win cultural battles
but to take offense that's what it's all
about taking offense conspicuously
vocally flamboyantly getting mad this is
what the backlash does indignation
is the great aesthetic principle of
backlash culture i mean everything seems
to piss them off
and and they they the way they react is
is not by getting unpissed off right by
remedying the situation but instead by
documenting and cataloging their disgust
that's what they do and the result is
what i call the plenty plaint
which is this amassing this this style
that they have this tendency they have
to amass
thousands and thousands of petty
unrelated beefs with the world now the
purpose of the plenty plain is not to
evaluate the hated liberal culture that
surrounds us it's a horizontal rather
than a vertical mode of criticism and it
aims not to evaluate but to infuriate us
with dozens and hundreds and thousands
of stories of the many many tiny ways in
which the world that surrounds us
assaults family values uses obscenities
disrespects parents foments revolution
and so on
the purpose of the plenty plane is just
to wind us up it it offers no resolution
it just constantly reminds us that we
can never win
the plenty plate is the rhetorical
device that makes bill o'reilly's tv
show such a hit as he gets indignant one
day about the insane clown posse and
then gets indignant the next day about
the man boy love association
the plenty plaint is the modus operandi
for that backlash favorite which you
find everywhere on the internet the
political correctness scoreboard in
which ridiculous examples of religious
are i'm sorry of liberal intolerance you
know discrimination against christians
silly mascot issues this kind of thing
many many examples of this are always
heaped up by the thousands and the
thousands and the thousands
now although it typically describes only
the most
superficial
aspects of american life
i think the obvious implication of the
plenty plain is that liberalism can be
held responsible for the world around us
that each of these objections to the way
that other people drive to the way that
they cut in line
right the way that they talk with their
mouthful all of these things are somehow
indictments of the left
now it doesn't matter in conservative
movement culture that liberals have long
since lost their power over government
in the backlash mind liberalism is still
what changes our mores what determines
what's on tv and in the magazines and
what makes or i should i should say
interprets the laws and there is nothing
not the constitution not our guns not
electoral victories nothing that can
protect us from liberalism or slow it
down it's an alien conspiratorial force
that can't be held accountable and that
does not care when its projects go awry
viewed through the eyes of the backlash
liberalism's impositions are so
intolerable and so bizarre and taken
with so little regard for the
sensibilities of the regulated that
liberalism really will stop at nothing i
mean who knows what precedent the
supreme court's going to pull out of its
ass next
or which figure of everyday speech the
commissars of political correctness will
criminalize even as they enlarge the
list of swear words permissible for
broadcast on tv
of which i just uttered
backlash culture abounds with bizarre
speculation about what atrocity the
liberals will inflict on us tomorrow
each wild suggestion made and received
with complete seriousness
check it out the liberal elite is going
to outlaw major league sports they're
going to forbid red meat
they're going to mandate special
holidays for transgendered war veterans
i didn't make any of these up by the way
i've heard all of these proposed they're
gonna hand over our neighborhood to an
indian tribe they're gonna decree that
only gay couples can adopt children
they're gonna ban the bible
in fact on one uh
one list server i was following there's
actually dispute over whether or not the
bible had or had not already been banned
in canada
surely the land of the liberal elite
right they speak french up there and
that sort of thing right
anyhow to believe that they they drink a
lot of lattes i understand as well to
believe that liberalism is is uh
all-powerful which they do believe makes
for a singularly negative and depressing
movement culture to be a populist
conservative is to be a fatalist
to believe in a world where your side
will never win indeed where your side
almost by definition cannot win
where even the most shattering electoral
victories always turn out to be hollow
and the liberal stranglehold on life can
never be broken
one of their uh an image that you
frequently come across in conservative
circles is the image of someone being
bound and gagged
and this is because they think that
conservatives dare not speak their mind
for fear of having the h-bomb charges of
racism or sexism dropped on them
even worse
they believe conservatives are without
agency they're hapless victims adrift in
a fatalistic universe where only
liberals may act and where of course
every act undertaken by those liberals
is an imposition on the good people of
middle america
now what's funny about this uh negative
and depressing movement culture is that
it is genuinely attractive
and even seductive in some ways for one
thing you know the most immediate point
is that it gets conservative lawmakers
off the hook for their flagrant failure
to make any headway in the culture wars
more importantly though this culture
offers conservatives a seductive way of
dealing with a hostile universe or an
unfair universe which we all deal with
but the backlash provides its followers
people who sign up with a ready-made
identity
in which the glamour of authenticity
combined with the narcissism of
victimhood
becomes available to almost anyone
you're the salt of the earth the very
beating heart of america the backlash
tells all those cranky suburbanites who
tune into fox news and yet you are
unfairly and outrageously
persecuted now in some ways i think
conservative culture resembles the most
vulgar kind of post-colonial theory
whatever the issue you're not at fault
it tells its followers you're always a
victim besieged by a hateful overclass
from the east coast or worse from france
they're always pressing their alien ways
down on you so conservative culture
absolves people of responsibility for
what goes on around them and it allows
them both in politics as well as in
their private life to resolve all
disputes by pointing their fingers at
the outside world and blaming it all
depraved liberal elite
now none of what i have described so far
would make sense were it not for a
critical rhetorical move that
conservatives then make which is the
systematic erasure
of the economic
now as we all know
some species of conservatives are very
happy to discuss economics with you of
course and you can find them any day of
the week
at the country's management schools or
it's business magazines or up in chicago
where i used to live at the university
of chicago economics department
or in the wall street journal or any
business pages for that matter prattling
on about the mystical inerrancy of the
free market and the benevolence of
global capitalism but most of the
conservatives that i discuss in in this
current book what's the matter with
kansas don't say anything about the
business world at all
or very very little i should say now the
erasure of the economic is a necessary
precondition for most of your basic
backlash ideas
for example it's only possible to think
that the news media is slanted to the
left if you never take into account who
owns the news media and if you never
turn your critical eye on something like
a cnbc
or the business section of your local
newspaper
the university campus can only be
imagined as a place dominated by
leftists if you leftists if you never
consider econ departments or business
schools who have all the money these
days most importantly it's only possible
to understand pop culture itself
as the product of liberalism if you have
blinded yourself to the most fundamental
of economic realities uh namely that the
networks and the movie studios and the
ad agencies and the publishing houses
and the record labels are in fact
commercial enterprises
so in some ways i think the backlash
vision of life the backlash vision of
the way that the world works is nothing
more than an old-fashioned and i mean
really old-fashioned i mean 1930s style
leftist vision of the world but with the
economics drained out
where the muckrakers of old used to
fault capitalism for botching this
institution and that the backlash
thinker simply changed the script to
blame liberalism so instead of
capitalism screwing everything up it's
liberalism liberalism is a stand-in for
capitalism
and i'll give you an example of how this
shift works up until the late 1960s
in america the standard criticism of the
press that you used to hear and i mean
everyone from upton sinclair up to aj
liebling the columnist for the uh for
the new yorker magazine the standard
criticism that you used to hear was that
newspapers tilted to the right
serving the interests of the capitalists
who published them right people like
william randolph hearst or colonel
mccormick up in chicago
and also the capitalists who advertised
in it
today though as everybody knows it is
liberal reporters and liberal editors
who are supposed to twist the news to
match their elitist personal preferences
and the same kind of treatment is also
administered to the old critiques of
higher education the legal establishment
the foreign policy world
and of course the government itself with
each institution now said to be a
slavish servant
not of the interests but of liberalism
even the rhetoric of the backlash with
all of its you know regular guy
flourishes sometimes appears to me to
have been lifted whole cloth from the
proletarian 1930s and this is a point
that i make because one of my hobbies is
to buy um
novels
from this genre they used to call
proletarian literature proletarian
fiction they were all published in the
1930s and i buy these on ebay and you
know as i collect them
they're kind of interesting anyhow you
read these a lot you start noticing some
curious similarities between those and
today's you know backlash culture for
example the idea that average people are
helpless pawns caught in a machine run
by the elite basically basically comes
straight from the vulgar marxist copy
book
which taught generations of party
members that they inhabited i don't mean
republican party that they inhabited a
deterministic world where agency was
something reserved for capitalists or
more precisely for capital itself
and the old old-school proletarian
writers love nothing more than to mock
the frenchified pretensions of the
effete
devitalized upper classes
just read an article or two by
mike gold i doubt anybody here remembers
mike gold he was the literary editor of
the daily worker but you start reading
his stuff and then put it side by side
with uh ann coulter or rush limbaugh or
something it's the same stuff they just
turned the stereotype on liberals
now one problem that the old left did
not have
was in explaining how the world worked
class struggles they thought could
pretty much account for everything but
if you drain the economics out of the
world you're left with very few tools
for explaining anything
why is our culture the way it is
why does tv get coarser with every
passing year
what makes certain styles or words or
ideas suddenly so visible while others
disappear
each of these are matters of dark bitter
obsession
among backlash conservatives and yet the
only answer that they can ever provide
is to blame liberalism
our culture is the way it is because
manipulative liberals have decided to
make it so
now the truth is
the truth is he said so i know the
answer here right i'm part of the
liberal elite i know the answer
i read it in a book
the truth is that the culture that
surrounds us and that persistently
triggers
new explosions of backlash outrage is
largely the product of business
rationality it's made by writers and
actors who answer to editors and
directors and producers who answer to
senior vice presidents and ceos who
answer to wall street bankers who demand
profits above all else and from the mega
mergers of the media giants to the
commercial timeouts during the football
game to the plots of the hollywood
movies and to the cyber fantasies of
wired and fast company we live in a free
market world
the supreme court does not make american
culture neither does planned parenthood
or even the aclu it is business that
speaks to us over the tv set always in
the throbbing tones of cultural
insurgency forever shocking the squares
humiliating the pious queering tradition
and crushing patriarchy it's because of
the demands of consumerism
that our tv is such a sharp tongued
insulter of family values and such a
zealous promoter of every species of
social deviance it's thanks to new
economy capitalism
and its cult of novelty and creativity
that our bankers refer to themselves as
revolutionaries
which they do and our discount stock
brokerages tell us that you know owning
shares is going to smash conformity and
usher in the rock and roll millennium
which they also do we're encouraged to
drink dr pepper because it'll make us
more of an individual to consume
starbucks because it's so goddamn
authentic right to pierce our our navels
and ride souped up jet skis and eat
jello because each of these are such
extreme experiences
tad and i were in a 7-11 the other day
and he bought he bought a can of extreme
orange soda i mean
counterculture is so ordinary and so
commercial and so business friendly
today that a school of urban theorists
now thrives going around the country and
instructing municipal authorities on the
fine points of luring artists hipsters
and rock bands to their cities on the
grounds that where these groups go
corporate offices will follow
you've heard about this stuff i'm not
making it up listen
the free market doesn't respect family
values any more than it respects the
integrity of small towns out on the lone
prairie or the architecture of detroit
or the well-being of boeing workers down
in wichita or the water levels in the
ogallala aquifer it doesn't give a damn
the free market is a destroyer not a
conserver all that is solid it melts
into air
i think
that ordinary working class people are
right to hate this culture
i think they are right to feel that they
have no power over it and to notice that
it makes them feel inadequate and stupid
the middle americans after all those are
the people that the ads and the sitcoms
and the movies warn us against they're
the you know the prudish preacher who
forbids dancing remember that movie
footloose yeah
the prudish preacher who forbids dancing
the dullard husband who foolishly
consumes brand x the racist dad who
beats his kids the square cowboy that
gets gunned down by the alternative
cowboy
the hard hat who just doesn't get it as
you would have seen in every tv
commercial run on cnbc in the 1990s now
conservatives are very good not every
single one but many conservatives are
very good at complaining
about these things what they refuse what
they always refuse to think about what
they refuse to examine are the forces
that create the problem
take for example uh the backlash
bestseller from the mid 1990s in which
the author
complains about his liberal boss
who thinks and this is the quote it was
oppressive to have to wear a tie
now it's true
as we all remember it is true that in
the 1990s there was a movement against
formal dress in the white collar
workplace we all remember that the
mistake is when conservatives attribute
this change as they do to leftist
traitors boring from within
now as as everyone who had a job in the
1990s remembers the kind of people
who were who thought casual dress was so
great were not communists
but in fact the the hyper capitalist
heroes of the new economy the business
revolutionaries as they like to call
themselves who in fact benefited so
handsomely from the votes of angry
conservatives everywhere
it's not because radicals have secretly
taken over the world that
tradition-minded people feel so
uncomfortable these days it's because
the new turbocharged capitalism that we
live in has no place for them and it and
it tells them this every chance it gets
it tweaks a nation of squares in all of
its signature cultural outlets in
management books and tv commercials and
tom peters powerpoint presentations
tom peters powerpoint presentations
consumer capitalism's only use for the
ramrod straight man is in showing
showing him to be visibly upset by the
liberating potential of some uh corn
chip you know
filming him as he invades against some
soda pop because it's it breaks the
rules is too too extreme or lets the
consumer be too much of an individual or
whatever it is
but the backlash can never see it that
way
our culture is the way it is because
liberals have made it so
and this is the logical terminus
of backlash reasoning
when you've rejected
all the social science methods for
understanding the way things work on the
grounds of those that people in in
academia are biased and liberals and all
that when you've rejected all that when
you can't talk straight about social
class when you can't acknowledge that
free market forces might not always be
for the best
when you can't admit the validity of
even the most basic historical truths
these blunt tools are all that you're
left with
journalists and sociologists and
historians and musicians and
anthropologists and photographers all of
them do what they do because they are
liberals and liberals lie
liberals cheat liberals do anything in
fact that promises to advance their
larger partisan project i.e to create
more liberals and somehow to win
so liberalism is not in the backlash
mind liberalism is not a product of
social forces you know the labor
movement the environmentalist movement
that sort of thing liberalism is not a
product of social forces it is
a social force it is a juggernaut moving
according to a logic all of its own as
rigid and as mechanical as anything
dreamed up by the stalinists of
yesterday
now the um
the great backlash began back in the
late 1960s with the coming together of
two very different political factions
uh on the one hand you had the
traditional business republicans
with their faith in the free market and
who we call the moderates here in kansas
and then on the other hand the
people i grew up around and on the other
hand the working class middle americans
who we call the conservatives here the
middle americans who signed on to
preserve family values
and for the former group the
business-minded republicans the
conservative revival that has resulted
since those years has been fantastically
rewarding i mean after all they are
wealthier as a class today than ever
before in their lifetimes
but for the latter group
for the uh aggrieved middle americans i
think the experience has pretty much
been a bummer all around
i mean look all they have to show for
their republican loyalty
their 30 years of republican loyalty are
lower wages
more dangerous jobs dirtier air
a new overlord class that comports
itself like king farouk
and of course a crap culture whose moral
freefall continues without significant
interference from the grandstanding
chrysters that they send triumphantly
back to washington
every couple of years by all rights the
charm of republicanism should have worn
off for this part of the conservative
coalition a long long time ago i mean
after all how can you lament the shabby
state of american life while absolving
business of any responsibility for it
how can you complain so bitterly about
culture and yet neglect to mention the
main factor making culture what it is
how can you reconcile the two clashing
halves of the conservative mind
by believing in an all-powerful liberal
elite that's how
alone among the many many industries of
the world the backlash thinkers tell us
the culture industry just does not
respond to market forces
it does the ugly things that it does
because it is biased
by robotic alien liberals always trying
to drip their corrosive liberalism into
our ears
liberal bias exists because it must
exist for the rest of contemporary
conservatism to make sense
as in saint anselm's proof of the
existence of god which flummoxed
generations of our ancestors it simply
cannot be any other way
liberal bias has to be
therefore
it is thank you very much
all right now
we've only we only have a short time for
questions and then the c-span guys are
going to turn off the cameras or that's
what they were telling me so let's let's
get right to it
uh i guess you're going first
okay uh you've got the name of a state
in your title i do sir so i'd like to
ask about middle america and a little
bit of canada too
did you say canada canada yes canada
english-speaking canada okay okay uh why
are saskatchewan
at least one of the dakotas minnesota
wisconsin maybe iowa
so different politically from kansas and
nebraska
oh that's a good one that's a that's a
great question
and i
i don't have a perfect answer for that i
would suggest that in those states that
the farmer labor movements have survived
a lot longer than they have here you
take a place like iowa the farmers union
there is both is still powerful and uh
pretty radical
and in a lot of those other states
and especially like i've lived in
illinois up until quite recently the
labor movement is still very powerful in
those places
uh but uh no i don't have a good larger
cultural answer for that but
it is it is curious is it not now this
this is another thing that i have to
always mention is that i'm not talking
about this broad sweeping thing it's not
universal there are still pot here and
here in kansas of course still pockets
of places where the old uh the old way
of understanding class and the old
school populism still holds up here in
lawrence for example in topeka and
wichita
and especially in kansas city kansas
okay who else
nobody excellent i'm off
you guys should come down because
there's a microphone down here they want
you all to use
you've really tapped into some long
range historical forces in in your
analysis i wanted to go back to
1980
and the three promises that i heard as a
young actually son of republicans so
there may be some
bi-directional movement in this in this
conversion but reagan promised that he
would cut the
the social spending he would increase
military spending and he would cut the
deficit yeah
now i thought as a just a young college
student how can this be because it
sounds illogical that you'll have extra
money out of it and indeed it turned out
to be a huge bus budget fiasco and then
we saw
and it's back yes what was weird was we
had the interlude of clinton to prove
that that there that it was possible to
control that and that it seemed to be
better for
general prosperity yes but do you
remember the laffer curve
yeah well no the the theory was and you
got to remember when you're talking to
um so i'll let you go economists or
economic minded people that theory
trumps reality every time
but they had this thing called the
laffer curve and the idea the idea was
you uh you know you you do all this
military spending and you you uh you cut
the social spending and you cut taxes
especially that's the main ingredient
and you'll get the economy booming and
then the revenues from whatever taxes
you still have will go way up now i
should point out that the conservatives
you know they they don't like to give
bill clinton credit for anything but
they do like to take the credit for the
um for in fact they take the credit away
from him for the deficit having gone
away in the 1990s they say see it proves
the laffer curve theory after all but
what they really learned in the in the
1980s with those gigantic deficits was
that this is not something that really
is going to hurt them this is something
they can run the deficit up as high as
they want and reap you gotta remember
they for years and years and years
republicans accuse the democrats of
doing social spending in order to uh to
you know in order to boost their
political fortunes that that's the only
reason they were really doing it
and you know they were giving money to
their constituents and this sort of
thing and what they discovered is that
they could play that game too i mean i'm
not admitting that democrats did it
because how would i know but uh but
that's almost that's most certainly what
they're up to now that they have
discovered that uh that they can run the
deficit sky high and nobody gives a damn
and uh their their their constituents
benefit very you know do really well
from it
i wrote a um i'm gonna stop there okay
next question is how do you answer the
claim we frequently hear that businesses
rather than being servants of
of banks are actually the servants of
consumers whose tastes are determined by
forces that business has a little
control over how would they how would
that work where businesses are why are
banks you're talking about banks
specifically or business i'm talking
about business in general but the
businesses are servants of consumers
whose tastes are determined let's say
for argument's sake by the liberals
and so
uh
and so they're they're on the receiving
end that's right right and they're just
doing what's what's in their interest
but what's in their interest is being
determined for them by someone yes by
barbra streisand and all that that's a
that's a good no it's actually i'm sorry
i shouldn't that's that's a very good
question and the last book that i wrote
uh which was called one market under god
was about this theory which i call
market populism and this is the notion
that we express ourselves through free
markets and free markets are are
basically our democracy in action but
the thing is that it's actually really
really easy to show this is not the case
there are many many cases where uh you
know we don't get what we want uh i mean
i never get what i want they never make
a movie that i like damn it or
or you take something like um
something that's in the news recently
enron manipulating the uh california
uh the california energy market in order
to boost their profits which is now that
these memos have come out it's basically
an open shut case they most certainly
were not uh giving the public what it
wants they were doing the exact opposite
they were deliberately shutting down
reactors or power plants in order to
artificially push the price higher and
then you know trading on that
and so i think that um
obviously to some degree you know uh
there there is there is a grain of truth
in these things but i think that the
most of the evidence is on the other
side of the other side of the coin
uh yeah over here yeah hi i i'm not sure
if you're familiar with the work of
george lakoff from the rockridge
institute um
an organization uh that
um
concerned themselves with reframing the
debate
um george wikov says that for the past
30 years conservatives have poured
millions into think tanks
that
it's the use of language for example the
term family values for example the the
conservatives will throw that out there
and
and
it means it's it's called language right
um
but
on the other side you can't
position yourself as being
anti
you can't position
you can't position yourself as being
anti-family value right you can't
to take the opposite stance of that
family values even though it means
something else
or for example the other one he uses is
the term tax relief that's been
introduced into our language
particularly in this administration um
bush will use the term tax relief and
the media the press will will print it
you know verbatim
right exactly
that's another perfect example
and
um this this
part of what they talk about is
maybe using their attitude to counter
that like
for example they don't pay taxes in
afghanistan if you don't want to pay
taxes pal go to afghanistan
their own attitude and turn that
that's good
that's an excellent point and i've
recently moved to washington dc and so i
can i can see exactly what you're
describing in action
amuse myself but also because i'm always
looking for good material to write about
i go to these think tanks that you're
describing um where the you know uh
where they where they come up with these
things and the money that they have to
throw around is indeed staggering i
think particularly the cato institute
which is a libertarian group that is
funded by the uh or was originally
funded even founded by the uh some of
the koch brothers down down in wichita
and these people have been extravagantly
successful at uh one of the things that
you described they call it social
security reform
what they mean by that is getting rid of
it and replacing it with uh with with
accounts where you you can manage your
own money in the stock market and there
is no guaranteed return well it depends
on how they're going to work out there's
no guaranteed return there's instead
there's a you know
you get to manage your everybody has
their own portfolio and the charm of
this for conservatives is not because
it's going to let you retire or easier
it's going to be a better system or
something like that it's because that
way they can take the money away from
government because we all know
government uses the us government uses
the social security revenue
to fund other projects and then pays it
back later so they take that away and
pull the rug out from under activist
government and then at the same time
give wall street immense
influence over public policy i mean if
they do this
and you're a liberal politician who says
wants to make it easier for people to
form labor unions or something like that
and get a bill passed on congress you
know what that does to wall street i
mean the dow drops a thousand points in
a day or something like that and then
guess what you've done you have
destroyed the retirement of millions of
americans you're basically handing over
you know the politics of the country to
wall street um touch wall street and
you're dead that's what they want you
know yeah and they call it social
security reform and it sounds so nice
and i went down about you yeah i saw
newt gingrich speak at cato a little
while ago and it was just remarkable
amazing man
yeah
hello um it seems to me and i'd like you
to comment on this but that uh
a lot of the success in the
pushing cultural values issues um comes
from exploiting a split between people
who have a supernatural worldview and
people who have a naturalistic worldview
so like for instance here in kansas
there was a great example of evolution
us liberals believe that the world is
billions of years old and the salt of
the earth types believe that god
magically created the earth six thousand
years ago
and liberals have supernatural powers to
control the minds of people
until the glorious day
i know exactly what you're talking about
i do it all the time i'm forever you
know well
but so using our magical superpowers we
liberals can manipulate people's minds
and make them buy into a culture they
don't really want and and also deficits
don't really matter because legislators
have magical superpowers to be able to
give you increased social spending and
increased uh defense spending and also
cut your taxes at the same time um and
so i wonder if you could just comment on
that naturalist world view that i think
uh a lot of us defeat liberals have and
um and also on just the uh how ignorance
became cool because i don't know that
ignorance was always
a value of you know the universities
weren't always let me talk about those
things first of all the naturalistic
worldview this that is a term that they
actually use in the evolution debate and
i attended a
couple of uh anti-evolution meetings
here in the state or over in missouri
and uh
here's the funny thing about this is
that uh if you look deeply into their
literature
they there's a group out in seattle that
uh it's it's another think tank very
well funded and very um
very shrewd and they have uh one of
their things in addition to all the kind
of new economy technology libertarian
technology stuff they're also against
evolution why are they against evolution
well they've issued a document or they
put out this document where they they
tell uh you know people who are
interested in funding them i assume i
mean i don't know who else they put out
this document where they say if we if we
get rid of evolution if we you know
strategically attack evolution we can
pull the rug out from under this whole
you know
mess of the 20th century and we have
we'll have you know the 19th century
world with classical economics back this
will destroy all these problems all
these cultural problems that we have
whether it's you know teen pregnancy or
or kids being absent from school and
it'll also destroy what they call
socialism which they mean by which they
mean the welfare state and what's ironic
about that
is that william jennings brian
who was also a very religious man a
fundamentalist even but by today's
standards of you know
screaming liberal leftist
and he was very popular in the state of
kansas by the way also uh towards the
end of his life uh
decided to crusade against evolution but
for precisely the opposite reason
because he thought evolution led
automatically to social darwinism which
was reprehensible to him as a christian
which was you know which was vile he and
he didn't like contemporary cat he
didn't like capitalism he thought it
needed to be reformed and that you
should get rid of evolution for that
reason so it's amazing to me how this
has been flipped over the years
i i want to commend you for uh
you know as i i'm i'm going to be an old
guy i'm getting the harding of the
categories
and you've loosened my categories
considerably
and i continue to read you
over and over to just to absorb all the
content that you have in your i've read
the harper's i haven't yet to read the
book
but
what comes to mind is uh
is the solution
for liberals to be liberals
and the conservatives to be
conservatives in the old sense or
traditional senses
or is there any hope for either party
which i have long thought both of them
are bedfellows with the corporate
interests of the world not just our
country
and they are
they talk about screwing us over i mean
it's going on big time yeah or should we
form
a new party in this country
that would really be
closer to the people
[Applause]
i'm sincere in asking that because yeah
i don't have much time to put
wait i enter i don't have much time to
waste my energy with parties that aren't
being faithful to the people of the
united states of america yeah
that's that's great very well said
well let me put it this way well we did
it in kansas once before we did 100
years ago our ancestors did and they
formed the people's party which put
these yeah put these uh these brought
these problems to the fore and made the
other two parties think about them
you know said what are we gonna do about
capitalism that was the question it was
very simple and remember in the 1880s
and 1890s the two parties basically
agreed with each other the only issue
they fought over was the tariff should
it be high it should be low and the
populist said these are this is a sham
battle that was a term they love to use
these are false issues
face up to what's going on in our
society look at what's going on debate
this and what happened was they
got their party going and they it they
immediately became uh you know a player
on the national level and the democrats
moved to the left and absorbed them this
is what what brian did
and uh i don't know i don't think we uh
i mean that that was a great moment the
populist uh moment was was a fantastic
time and we're in a very similar sort of
situation now where we have this huge
issue right in front of us inequality
look what's going on in this society you
know where the ceos make
500 times as much as their average line
worker
you know and where these these these
wall street people are just walking off
with millions of dollars after telling
us after promising us all through the
1990s that the stock market was the
friend of little old ladies in
beardstown illinois remember that
the beardstown ladies and that the
mutual mutual fund revolution was going
to empower us all and we were all going
to be able to trade via the internet
we're going to be so much smarter than
all the insiders and the pros on wall
street it was all a lie
well anyhow
and now we're looking at this we're in
this situation and and you know uh and
and really neither of the two parties at
a national level is addressing it now
there's there are still democrats here
and there that do talk about these
things do a very good job about it and
some of them ran for president they
didn't get the nomination but they were
out
now i think
that the democrats
have to come around to um
well i'll i'll let me skip to the uh the
last chapter in the book i offer advice
to the democrats which of course uh you
know
who cares right nobody's gonna nobody
gives a damn and i'll tell you why in a
minute but uh
uh
the the for the last uh uh you know 15
20 years they've done what you described
the leadership of the democratic party
has said you know we can't play this old
old school economic populist game
anymore we can't be the democratic party
of roosevelt and truman and john f
kennedy and we can't try to talk to the
workers anymore because there's no money
in that we aren't going to get you know
politics in america runs on money you
have to have money to run those tv
commercials and you have to have a lot
of money and the only way you're gonna
get that is with um with the assistance
of corporate america and therefore they
have they've set out to make themselves
a safe party and they've uh pretty much
turned their backs on that constituency
that made them what they were that
constituency of of roosevelt and o'brien
and all the rest of it they've turned
their backs on that and the sick thing
is that they've allowed the republicans
to capture the language of social class
we're living in this period where social
class has returned with a vengeance you
know where there's this huge divide
between rich and foreign america and
who's speaking to that that republicans
are speaking to that that's astounding
to me and i i would think that just out
of self-preservation the democrats would
have to bring back some of the old
economic populism just to confront just
to confront that that republican
pseudo-populism just to to do something
to interrupt it uh and the reason they
won't is because then that would scare
off their camp their donors they would
that would scare off the
you know the people that fund them
tell them you're saying it's time for a
new party yeah
all right
yeah
i'd like to first commend you for i
think you did a really good job
analyzing the uh
the cause and
the effect and how the backlash is
structured
but um one thing i'd like to
hear you expand on a little bit is
actually the um
i mean i get kind of the impression from
you know hearing you speak tonight and
reading the book that
it almost sounds like in your opinion
the cultural issues are
pretty much constructed by the backlash
and by the leaders in order to um you
know convince the uh
the common people to go republican but
i'd like to hear how you'd address i
mean because
some of these issues are i mean there
are very serious issues about how
how america is constructed i mean i
think
you know the
let's say the church state issues um
issues of public expression um
you know things like equal rights for
gay couples things like that are
essential to
you know america and what kind of
country we want to be whether we want to
be a you know pseudo-fascist country or
a country where people can really be
free
and so i think
i just want to hear your opinion do you
think that um
how should democrats and people on the
left
capture these issues so that
they can work for us instead of against
us
that's a great question now look i'm a
i'm a liberal right down the line and
i'm a liberal on the cultural issues as
well as on the economic issues and i
think that the mistake has been to for
the for the for the democratic party to
abandon the uh the economic issues and
i'll tell you why it's because it allows
this the part of the fantasy of these
cultural issues is that they are for the
people who are motivated mobilized by
them whether it's abortion or whether
it's gay marriage or something each of
these always comes with the claim that
it overpowers everything else you care
about it overpowers everything else in
life and the only reason this claim is
able to be made and people are people
believe it is because the democrats
aren't out there with offering them
something else that might be more
important than that
and they're
i mean uh we can all we we all know
examples of this of uh well i'll give
you an example from from the book
that when
clinton did his move to the you know
become a
to sign off on the republican economic
republican economic agenda namely by
doing things like agreeing to nafta
banking deregulation this kind of thing
but when he signed nafta i know of uh
working class people here in kansas who
said there's no longer any difference
between the parties on the economic
issues all that leaves me with are these
cultural issues and in that environment
they're gonna they're gonna vote
republican now i think that you can have
a liberal stand on the cultural issues
as long as you do something to make it
you know to make it so they don't have
so they don't they can't make that
choice so easily so that there's at
least something out there that you're
giving to these people but you know with
clinton and with the democratic
leadership council the democrats
basically took that away
and they've and you know look the
democratic leadership council which is
this centrist democrat group in
washington will always say well clinton
proves that our strategy is a success we
got this guy elected president twice
but they also lost congress
there are no democrats are no longer the
majority party in america and that's an
extraordinary thing when i was growing
up i thought that that was permanent
that the party of roosevelt would always
be the majority party in america it just
made sense to me but it's not that way
anymore and it's because the democrats
gave away you know gave up the fight on
those critical issues
i i hope i answered your question yeah
that's uh
that's how i see it too thanks
okay over here yeah hey um i really
enjoyed your article in harper's
magazine it seems that what you're
describing is a kind of an ongoing storm
of reactions it seems that um
it kind of tells something about the
culture i'm thinking about michael
moore's movie bowling for columbine i'm
wondering about our culture um
i'm also wondering if someone can
explain to me how exactly george bush is
not elite
um
because the way he walks
[Music]
the question the question is do we live
in a culture that is most energized when
it's payback time
and could this be something sourced from
a kind of a
um
itinerant creature culture that exists
in midwest
sort of i mean is
is it because we are so fascinated with
the book of revelation we hope it isn't
true
um
but so we're all just waiting for that
day i don't know that day i see you
getting a lot of signals about this you
know it's funny
[Music]
several times in kansas and i can't say
that all conservatives by this or even
many concerns by this was but was this
idea of either
that the
rapture could be speeded up or slowed
down
and that clinton
that scoundrel
has
had slowed it down by by bringing peace
between the israelis and the
palestinians
[Music]
you know armageddon and the final way of
judgment and then we don't get to get to
heaven damn it and this is reason enough
and then there's
that has a scheme for speeding up
rapture and their idea is they can go to
the um they can go to the holy land and
they can drill an oil well and they know
where to drill because they figured it
out by careful study of the book of
revelation and they know where to drill
it it's like you know near the dead sea
and they can drill this in and they're
going to find the oil and you know
they've done all these preliminaries
search you know a research and no it
doesn't indicate there's any oil there
but that just means that the oil is real
deep down which is real smart of god and
i'll tell you why because
that way when they find it
and they start you know israel starts um
producing lots and lots of oil it'll
because it's lower down and drain away
from the arab countries was provoking
armageddon and bringing on the rapture
so these people have this scheme for
like bringing on this gigantic world war
in which these two peoples
uh jews and muslims fight it out and
they don't get to go to heaven but if we
can get them fighting then you know
we'll all be you know hallelujah you
know and it's like you're like you just
you marvel at the levels of blasphemy
and idolatry you know implicit in this
it's like we can trick god into do it
you know and you're like oh my god how
does this stuff how do i mean and these
people are religious how do they do how
do they how do they figure this out
anyhow
it is it is extraordinary is it not
ah where are you william jennings brian
okay
it strikes me that in a lot of ways the
argument that you make and i think it's
very stupid one uh is a mirror image
that is held by liberals
they say the liberals on the media and
liberals go well the conservatives on
the media and it becomes very much a
divisive issue so that the liberals have
not gotten rid of the language of
reform or the language of revolution
but that these rhetoric set at each
other do not serve anything more than
rhetoric and they actually tend to
divide
and divide in a way where people can't
listen to each other and people cannot
converse and cannot communicate which
serves the purposes of the two parties
in power
that's an excellent and serves the whole
idea that there is liberal and there is
conservative when if you actually talk
to someone they range all over the place
and any sort of binary spectrum just
does not work and i wondered if you had
come across this i know in my travels of
western kansas a lot of the people i
talk to will say i'm an eisenhower
republican
which of course bears no resemblance to
the current republican party in fact
it's uh arguably left of clinton yeah uh
or even bob dole bob dole voted for
things in the 70s that were to the left
of clinton yeah exactly and so we've got
this need for heroes combined with this
divisiveness
that i think is fairly dangerous clinton
was here recently and spoke on a similar
issue but as i usually think of me
missed the point but uh
it's very much an issue
of who profits from this sort of thing
and i think that really both parties do
and it keeps third parties out
and i just wondered if you had anything
that's right and and polarization does
and this kind of like bogus polarization
where you know people are so angry and
you've got these two cultural profiles
that we're all supposed to fit into uh
yeah and it does it does serve their
interest and it is it's it's ludicrous
every people every individual is all
over the map let me but let me first
give you a funny anecdote
uh because that's what i do best but
this guy wrote in a letter to the
baffler magazines this magazine that i
edit out of chicago and he said he was
crossing the street in some city and a
car swerved by and almost hit him and
then the guy you know adding insult to
near injury rolled down the window and
said watch where you're going you
goddamn liberal
and so so the guy wrote in and said
first of all how did he know i was a
liberal
and second of all has it just become
this generic you know curse word is it
just something that you call people you
know and it is it it is funny and it's
ridiculous and let me just say this now
i obviously come across as a very very
partisan
person i mean duh right
i'm i'm on the left politically but
one of the problems with uh people with
my politics is that they don't think
about the backlash and they don't think
i mean the idea of conservatives
appealing to working class people
strikes it like as i said in the talk
strikes them is so ridiculous it's not
even worthy of consideration and one of
the things i really tried hard to do in
this book is um
sit down with these people the the
conservatives as well as the moderates
here in kansas and and listen to them
uh and and hear hear them out and hear
the whole story
uh which even the local media here
hasn't done a very good job of of doing
and uh listen to the whole thing and
these are good people i mean i didn't
there are very few of them that i mean a
lot of them i found very you know really
nice people really good people that in
other circumstances would have been you
know good friends of mine and that kind
of thing and it's uh you know
you can oh i don't know i don't want to
say we're all going to be together in
you know one big lovey you know
togetherness
but uh
but that the first step in dealing with
these things is understanding the
opposition now you know the
conservatives a guy like rush limbaugh
has no interest what so i mean look it's
all conspiracy theory and this kind of
thing but i think that if if if uh
responsible people want to resolve this
stuff or want to just end the uh you
know the the spiral of inequality that's
going on that you have to
talk to these people you have to
understand what they think
sorry if i could add one sure everything
which is that in just uh watching this
and attempting to place myself
in the other way around someone watching
this say in western kansas
would not respond to this
talk which has been very entertaining
very interesting as something well maybe
i should think to that because for
someone from that area and from that rim
we are a bunch of liberal eastern kansas
you know we're leaders yeah we're in
lawrence for god's sake yeah and
and so that
where do you begin to talk to them where
do you find a common ground where do you
begin to attempt
to change their opinions
oh wow that's
that's that's a tough one and i think it
is populism i think that this they're
talking a language of populism it's just
it's been shifted to this kind of
cultural thing and again i have to i you
know i can't emphasize this enough that
i really do think bringing back economic
populism i mean they're talking a
language that is really familiar to me
rush limbaugh talks a language that's
really familiar to me it's just that
the the the roles everything has been
switched it's like you know all the
actors have been changed a little bit
and uh
and i think that if we bring back the
original we can shatter this you know
ridiculous this false version
i hope we can anyways
but i'm such a pessimist i mean
okay over here um i'm sure you
understand this but i'd like to make it
crystal clear it appears
that that there is a deliberate
demonization
of educated people and particularly
edu the educated compassionate people
who care about the welfare of all the
people and because ron page is secretary
of education called the national
education association terrace he did he
called them terrorists i will send you
i'll talk
and and they are trying to destroy the
public education system with no child
left behind they're trying to destroy
the federal head start they threatened
head start teachers with jail if they
criticized the plan to kill head start
and head start sued on free speech
rights and one they are deliberately
demonizing the educated class who cares
about the people and we need to
understand
that
the ordinary kansans aren't engineering
this this is the think tanks and the
people who stole our presidency
and who want to they want to own the
airwaves they want the airwaves to be
privatized these are the people they are
trying to demonize the educated class
the teachers and the professionals who
are the only people that can organize
the society for the benefit of the
people
very good point let me just say and i
think they want us to start winding this
up is that right but uh
how many two more okay there's a whole
chapter in the book about
anti-intellectualism and i really do
think the rosetta stone to all of this
stuff is anti-intellectualism this is
the prejudice that brings all of these
weird ideas together and makes them all
make sense where it's you know the the
instead of the elite being merrill lynch
or or you know the people at enron or
something that the elite is uh people
who are educated people who think they
know better and there's this great
suspicion of the educated people and
this came out especially during the uh
fight over evolution where these people
deliberately provoked this this fight i
think in order to
bring out the worst uh in educated
people get some physical science
professors to come out and say yes but
look in the physical sciences there's
this consensus opinion and we know you
know we all believe in evolution and
they say yes but we the the people we
don't believe in evolution and who rules
there is it the people or is it you
experts and it's always this war against
expertise it's a manipulation of of the
culture to to discredit
uh educated people in educated discourse
yeah absolutely and uh yes and i'm sorry
i can't talk about this i would i could
talk about this for a long time there's
a great book richard hofstadter's uh
history is anti-intellectualism in
american life and it was published in
1963 but it explains the present better
than almost anything else out there it's
a fantastic book it is my
the north star to all of my thinking
about these cultural issues
yeah sometimes i think we
consider the
left's retreat to be something that the
left has just folded and we tend to talk
that way like what's wrong with the left
but you talk a lot about the
anti-abortion movement and the attacks
against the abortion clinics the murders
of the abortion doctors we go back not
very long before that there were the
number of assassinations of civil rights
leaders assassinations of politicians on
the left and an ongoing violence
against leaders on the left so how do
you think that plays into all of this
and you're uh you know you're totally
right about that but you're forgetting
one thing that's often it's easy to
forget because it's it's with us every
day and that is the suppression of the
labor movement i mean you don't have a
left without the labor movement and the
labor movement has been beaten in
america literally physically it didn't
go away because suddenly people didn't
want to be in labor unions anymore i
mean uh when reagan took off with
something like 20 20 or 25 percent of
the private sector workforce was in
labor unions today it's eight remember
he dissolved the air traffic controllers
union that's right and took on the union
and it's not just that it's the laws
have been changed it's very easy to fire
uh union organizers uh to do things like
this and uh this has been deliberately
suppressed now if you poll people 40 of
people say they would like to have a
union at work if you remove the the red
flag word labor union from the from the
question and you say well would you like
to have would you like to be able to
bargain with your with your boss or
would you like to be able to have some
say in how
the business that you work at how the
best the business is run it's like 90
they're like hell yeah of course i want
that but they don't get that
and look without a without a labor
without a labor movement you don't have
a left
and that's that's that's the critical
thing we always have to remember that
that's
the critical way in which the left has
been beaten in america and dismantled
actively yeah thank you very much okay
one more
all right it's uh
your fundamental contention that um the
free market or the market economy as it
exists today is antagonistic to the
average american you know as
a as a first-time voter you know i like
to look around i read the economist i
read the wall street journal i see that
this they argue that this is not the
case how can i rectify this in my own
mind i mean i i haven't read your books
maybe i should well it's not the case
that the free the free market is
is good that it's that it's doing
everything right yeah
well where would i start
the stock market crash i don't know the
uh the uh you know what enron did to the
to the people in california the way
they're pumping the ogallala aquifer dry
the way they're raising you know corn
out in western kansas for no reason
other than profit the market just visit
detroit sometime and look what it did to
to that city i mean i'm sorry i wrote a
book just a whole book filled with uh
examples of the way and i know you
you're setting you're being very kind
and setting me up here but i i've been
thinking about this other issue for so
long
uh
the the many many ways in which the the
the free market uh treats us badly hmm
that should just be a setup i'm sorry
i'm just not in that that that frame of
mind right now but uh there's a book
called one market under god which i
wrote and which i highly recommend
i'll be sure to check it out no but uh
the you know the ways in which it
rewards people for example that some
people you know and the way that that
it's made health care inaccessible i
mean there's a million ways in which and
the way if it was left to its own
devices which is pollute like mad
and you know drive wages down autumn you
know as as far as it could to the point
where you have to pay to get a job or
something like that and i'm not making
that up that happens uh these are all
things that it would do if it was left
to its own devices and there's there's
no question with that the the free
market has to be reined in in order for
a real real democracy to happen all
right thank you sure thing
thank you very much
[Applause]
thomas frank is founding editor of the
baffler magazine what's the matter with
kansas is published by metropolitan
books an imprint of henry holt visit
henryholt.com for more information
now another view on culture in america
new york times columnist david brooks is
author of the new book on paradise drive
this talk is an